is 911 how many years have you been
doing this
now uh six five or six is it fun or do
it feel like it's just sort of like for
me after season 4 five it started to
like go okay this is redundant I'm doing
the same thing I know what I'm doing
here it's kind of or does it get because
you have a complicated you know
character and relationships and stuff
like that so is it something that you
truly enjoy still doing or you're like
you're ready to move on to the next
thing you know I do still enjoy doing it
I love the people I've been very lucky
to have this job um it's it sounds awful
because it it was so much work but like
my character started off so in so much
turmoil and so much drama and so much
trouble and everything that it was so
fun to
play but then the audience really wanted
her to get like happy and kind of
normalized again and that part is hard
for me because I really liked I really
liked playing I really it was the one of
the first times that I didn't have to
just play like the Happy sweet nice girl
you know what I mean and so I I miss I
miss Maddie's turmoil a little bit which
sounds awful to say because you should
want for you know people to be happy and
and joyful um but I do miss her turmoil
a little bit so um it's it's still an
amazing job that I love doing but I do
miss I do miss that so I'm I'm always
like okay we we have something get
messed up again like she screw up
another 911 call and it'd be her fault
and then she has to report to the you
know yeah something I told her I told
her to get the gun and then she shot
herself it was it was my mistake I don't
know what I was thinking and then you go
into alcoholism and have to go to AA and
you're really upset about this and you
visit the
mom I love how her issues always come up
and and we have done like last season
was sort of an issue shoess season for
her um and so I'm hoping that in this
next one maybe we can you know they can
come back again just just a little every
now and then because it's fun for me
they're hard days when I have to do all
that but I secretly love it um so I
think that that would be that would be
fun and then I feel like I'm I feel like
I'm ready for like my Christmas movie
era wait a minute you want to start
doing Hall
Mark I mean I don't like lifetime like I
don't know I just have never
I've never done the Christmas thing I
have so many friends that have done
those and they love them I want to do it
ER Durant Amanda cluts like like they
love doing them and it's fun and you
could write your own if you want and you
could produce and you could do all that
you you know so I'm ready to step into
like my Christmas movie era too and I
feel like some of my friends are like no
that's what happens when you're in your
40s and you go do Christmas movies and
I'm like but I am in my 40s and I want
to do Christmas movies so I'm kind of
looking forward to doing something like
that maybe after 911 to kind of you know
be like emergencies and then Joy well I
can't maybe think about like if you do a
Christmas story maybe I'm your alcoholic
brother why don't you come direct to why
don't you come direct a Christmas movie
I I would do that if you were in it I
would do we'd have a blast that would be
fun I would do that I would do it if it
was fun and it was like you know just
for would would you be like the the guy
in a Christmas movie I'd like to be the
alcoholic brother that kind of gets a
[__] gets a [__] together at the end
that's not done a lot no I'm kidding I
could
be how about the guy that you don't
think she's GNA end up with like the guy
that the delivery guy I'm delivering
Amazon all the time I'm delivering yeah
I'm delivering Amazon packages all the
time and I'm just like hey great you're
like hey would you mind putting that out
there blah you know I'll take care of
that for you I'll do that hey you look
really nice today Mrs uh Johnson and uh
you know all of a sudden you're like
he's really nice and he's cute but he's
the delivery guy I I don't know if I can
and then I say you know I'm actually a
millionaire I just do this for fun we
should hang out I'm reconsidering I'm
reconsidering my offers yeah it's a bad
idea I've really blown it I'm not sure
I'm not sure have you ever seen a
Christmas movie uh Christmas
Story um Christmas
vacation I okay I haven't seen any
lifetimes yeah you gota you got to watch
like the like you know send me one send
me one that you think is good you should
watch Amanda's it's great oh I did see
some of that I liked it you did a really
good job fit for Christmas yeah she's
great that's right I did see that that
was it who's amazing and also my friend
so proud of Amanda's fantastic wait
didn't you introduce me to her yes